[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Demi Lovato definitely made
rihanna proud to working to her debut
single pon de replay during a recent
work out meanwhile flip or flop star
Christina el Moussa has been showing off
the results of her hard work in the gym
on Instagram I'm doing I'm doing really
good I'm in a really good place the kids
are happy they're healthy the mother of
two also seems to be in love with her
new french bulldog puppy here she is
smooching her new quote boyfriend kashi
I like to work right I'd rather worked
and sit at home it's a good thing it
seems we may have gotten a hint about
Sarah Paulsen's next big role during
Sunday's American Horror Story roanoke
paleyfest panel paulson's frequent
collaborator Kathy Bates repeatedly
referred to her as the people's princess
a nickname given to the late Princess
Diana we don't know if Bates was simply
joking or teasing fans but we do know
Paulson is confirmed for the next season
of feud which will follow Prince Charles
and Princess Diana's tumultuous
relationship
the internet went nuts after seeing this
commercial which originally aired in the
UK featuring Harry Styles and a cryptic
date April 7th which many fans believe
could mean he's releasing his debut
single
you